so here we have the graph y is equal to
G of X we have a little point
discontinuity right over here at X is
equal to 7 and what we want to do is
figure out what is the limit of G of X
as X approaches 7 so essentially we say
well what is the function approaching as
the inputs in the function are
approaching 7 let's see so if we input
as the input to the function approaches
7 from values less than 7 so if X is 3 G
of 3 is here G of 3 is right there G of
4 is right there G of 5 is right there G
of 6 looks like it's a little bit more
than or a little bit less than negative
1 G of 6.5 looks like it's around
negative 1/2 G of negative 6 point 9 is
right over there looks like it's a
little bit less than 0 G of negative 6
point 9 9 9 looks like it's a little bit
it's still less than 0 it's a little bit
closer to 0 so it looks like we're
getting closer as X gets closer and
closer but not quite at 7 it looks like
the value of our function is approaching
0 let's see if that's also true from
values for X values greater than 7 so G
of 9 is up here looks like it's around 6
G of 8 looks like it's a little bit more
than 2 G of 7 point 5 looks like it's a
little bit more than 1 G of seven point
one looks like it's a little bit more
than 0 G of 7 point 1 looks like it's a
little bit more than 0 G of seven point
zero one is even closer to zero G of
seven point zero zero zero zero zero
zero or one looks will be even close to
zero so once again it looks like we are
approaching zero as X approaches 7 in
this case as we approach from larger
values of 7 and this is interesting
because the limit as X approaches 7 of G
of X is different than the functions
actual value G of 7 when we actually
input 7 into the function when we
actually input 7 into the function we
can see the graph tells us that the
value of the function is equal to 3 so
we actually have this point discontent
you
sometimes called a removable
discontinuity right over here and this
is I'm not going to do a lot of depth
here but this is starting to touch on
how we one of the ways that we can
actually test for continuity is if the
limit as we approach a value is not the
same as the actual value of the function
at that point well then we're probably
talking about or actually we are talking
about a discontinuity